hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over my list of the
top six queen sacrifices of all time and
we have some good ones some from a long
time ago
some from last year some from the world
championship
the final move in the entire tournament
and one from
the what i think is the greatest chess
game
that has ever been played so with that
let's go ahead and dive into
my list
coming in at number six from the 2010
world team championships we have boris
gaofan versus
nakamura now this one almost didn't make
the list
only because nakamura tried over and
over to sacrifice his queen and gal fan
just said
no my friend i'm not gonna let you do
that to me
so at the end of the day did not
actually sacrifice the queen but for his
efforts i've put him in at
number six just because it's such a
beautiful variation to watch nakamura
starts out with knight takes here on
g2 attacking the rook pawn takes c7
attacking the queen
getting ready for a queen sacrifice
potentially knight takes e1 but it would
be a
losing proposition if the pawn takes
here
because gin pawn to g2 this is checkmate
the king is
cornered here nowhere to go that would
not be good so instead queen takes here
on e1
as you can expect pawn g2 forcing the
king to come up here g2
rook g7 setting up a future attack here
king comes back h1
and then bishop to h3 just an amazing
move right here says yeah you can
still take my queen here because if you
do same thing is going to happen with
that pawn
here on g2 but now it's the bishop
bishop to g2 this is going to be
checkmate so galfan says i still can't
take that queen i want to i want you to
make
kevin's video here but i can't i have to
play
bishop here to f1 nakamura says i'm
going to give you another chance i'm
going to play
queen to d3 go ahead and take my queen
please go ahead and take your
my queen with your bishop because then
the bishop comes
here to g2 as we already said this is
checkmate so uh gaffon recognizes that
he cannot do this
he instead plays knight takes here on e5
just takes a pawn and then we see the
bishops come off the board
but then two knights come off the board
queen takes here on
c3 after rook two c1
queen takes here on e5 and then after
the exchange right here queen two e6
nakamura is
up a piece going into the end game
and so gaufon resigns in this position
so really nice just trying to sacrifice
that queen
but that's why it did make number six on
our list
coming in at number five we have mccall
tall one of the greatest attacking
players of all time in 1969 facing off
against grandmaster suitin
and mccall's all starts out with knight
to e6
pawn can't take it's being pinned down
by the queen here on h5
bishop takes pawn recaptures you have
the pawn queen
and rook all eyeing down this f7 square
black decides let's go ahead and get the
queen to back up a little bit let's go
ahead and play
pawn to g6 force the queen back
set up some defense here things should
be good colts all says that's not the
game we're playing my friend
i'm trying to make the chess website's
video
in the future and he's plays queen takes
here on
e five after the pawn recaptures pawn
takes
f7 sutin decides to go ahead and resign
he realizes he made a
terrible mistake anytime tall
sacrificing their queen you know you're
pretty much
done with so in this position he
resigned now if he continued
there's no good way for him to continue
king 2f8 last checkmate bishop here to
h6 that's not gonna work here
if instead he stays along the eighth
rink
well then all of a sudden the pawn
pushes forward and you exchange that
pawn
for a rook that's not gonna work here
now the rook is hanging here on a8
bishop to f5 the knight and the pawn
can't capture its double check here the
king has to move that's not going to be
good
if instead doesn't come to the eighth
rank maybe king to d7
still bad news bishop here f5
double check king has to move bishop
comes back e4
this is attacking the king after the
king moves the rook
is going to fall there's just there's no
good moves eventually the pawn can
promote up here to f8
uh so black was going to lose anyway so
tall doing what he does best sacrifice
material sacrificing queens
to win a beautiful game
coming in at number four we have two of
the top chess
programs playing against each other
these are programs better than
any chess human in the entire world it's
crazy to
actually watch them sacrifice a queen to
win a game
but that's exactly what we saw in this
recent match between
komodo and winter komodo playing the
white pieces a
much stronger chess engine than winter
but winter is still
a very strong engine and komodo starts
out with
queen two h5 in this position eyeing
down this
f7 square at least it looks like that to
some extent
we do see winter play rook to e7
and then komodo said that's actually not
what i was looking to do
i have other plans and that is to
sacrifice a queen
to make this video and after the king
takes here
you can see rook takes h3 king comes
back here to
g8 and then the move knight to
g6 and this is the dagger there's no
real way to stop this this pawn and this
is where it all kind of sets up from
is being pinned down by the bishop here
on
b3 so the pawn can't move to stop this
knight at all so the knight's just
hanging out there the other pawn here on
h7
was taken by the queen that's what the
whole sacrifice was set up from
and now rook 2 h8 how do you really stop
that you can delay it a little bit
so queen 2 h5 yeah delays it by a move
rook down here to e1
check but then after that it is game
over and one of the best chess engines
out there
falls to a queen sacrifice
from komodo
coming in at number three we have a game
from just two months ago the 2020
russian championships white's played by
dubov and this is his
immortal game 24 years old already have
an immortal game that people have raved
about
and his opponent playing the black
pieces sergey kardayaki and what's nice
about this
is we see a sacrifice and the game
doesn't
end for 20 more moves sometimes you see
a queen sacrifice and it's two or three
moves later and it's like okay i can
i can start to piece together uh why he
came up with that combination but when
you start looking at 20 moves down the
road
you start to wonder how in the world was
he able to calculate that in this
position here
we see cardiac plays bishop to e6
and duboff says i'm gonna go ahead and
sacrifice my queen here
on g6 after the pawn takes
then the rook takes here on e6 attacking
the queen you can see
there's a lot of attacks and potential
threats
happening here the queen's under attack
but once the rook moves that's a
discovered attack on the
king right here we see queen to f7 makes
a ton of sense here bishop comes back to
c3 galling up some material here king to
h8 got to get it
off that diagonal here rook comes back
attacking the queen
queen f5 rook up here to e7 both of
these bishops still doing a lot of work
you can see this dark square bishop
eyeing down the g7 square along with
that rook here
so rook to g8 let's go and exchange that
for
the bishop rook the g8 but now it's just
playing defense mode pawn takes c7
preparing to
promote to the eighth rank here queen
comes back to c2
bishop e5 centralizing that king comes
out of the way bishop
b6 pawn h3 just a little safe square for
that king here king h7
work over here to e1 getting all of his
pieces
developed and threatening uh in
combination with each other pawn to a3
king h2 we have pawn to g5
at night d4 centralizing at the knight
here
and then after a few moves later
and a few more pieces come off the board
knight c5 check rook over here to d8 and
in this position
cardiac decided to resign too much
material
for him to cope with in the end game so
fantastic combination to see
that queen sacrifice over here for a
night
knowing that because you have so many
threats that he can win the game
20 moves later and this could have gone
on it could have been 25
30 different moves later so that is why
it is number three
on our list
coming in at number two we have magnus
carlsen winning
the 2016 world championships with a
walk-off queen sacrifice if you're going
to do that you're obviously going to
make
the top six list of all-time queen
sacrifices magnus carlsen facing off
against sergey karyakin
karjak can make in this list twice for
probably the reasons he doesn't want to
but kudos to him for making the world
championship against bagnes crossing and
taking it to tie breakers
i have a whole series on that if you
want to watch those videos but the
tiebreaker is definitely
more exciting than the rest of those
games but in this magnus carlson he's
under attack
brings his king back here to h1 queen
down to f2
sergey kerry i can say i think i can win
this i think i can be world champion i
can play queen 2 g2 this thing is good
to go
magnus crosston says no no no my friend
i play rook to c8
king 2h7 and then we have walk-off time
we have queen 2h6 queen sacrifice
and in this position senator karjatkins
said you got me
you're the goat i resign magnus carlsen
wins the world championship
because if the pawn takes here then rook
takes here on f7
and this is checkmate
fantastic way uh to win remember in this
tiebreaker these are rapid games so
there's not a lot of time to think for
magnus carlsen to be under this pressure
and then find a queen sacrifice to win
the world championship
that is why he is the greatest of all
time
coming in at number two
coming in at number one we have donald
byrne facing off against
bobby fischer in the game of the century
now it's not hyperbole although i do
think it is a very good game that's just
what people call it the game was that
good in chess
also happens to have what i think is the
greatest queen sacrifice
of all time from bobby fischer in this
position
fischer playing the black pieces we see
burn
play bishop to c5 attacking this queen
here on
b6 bobby fischer says okay i have an
in-between move don't have to
worry about that queen right now i can
play rook tay or rook two e8
check king comes to f1 and then bobby
fischer
decides you know what actually i don't
need that queen here on b6
because i'm just better with all my
other pieces and he plays
bishop to e6 so go ahead and take my
queen if you want to and that's what
burn does
obviously when someone gives you their
queen takes that material here on b6
then bobby fischer starts the attack
first taking here on
c4 check and then there is
lots of tactics going on here moving the
knight around with discovered attacks
continuously putting pressure on his
opponent
with checks and then moving around
taking this bishop here attacking the
queen right here
as the queen moves around always
attacking his opponent gobbling up more
material here
on the board whether that's a pawn a
rook doesn't matter bobby fischer trying
to gobble
all of that up here and at the end of
the day you see byrne doesn't have too
much material he has a queen here on
d8 trying to attack but can't really do
anything by himself here
bishop here on d5 stops the queen from
really
getting into the defense over here
knight to e4
centralizing but you can see bobby
fischer does so well
with all of his pieces and then once the
bishops are in the center of the board
he has this rook here on the second
rank here realizing okay i have all
these squares blocked off for the king
now i just have to put the finishing
touches here with my bishops and my
knights
that's exactly what he does with a
checkmate here
rook 2 c 2.
so congratulations to bobby fischer i
know he was really trying in the game of
the century
to be the top spot in this video and he
succeeded so congratulations to
bobby fisher hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video of
my list of the top six queen sacrifices
of all time
i'm curious in the comments below what
you think is the greatest
queen sacrifice of all time if i missed
one feel free to let me know
in the comments below if there's other
videos you'd like me to do
maybe it's the top rook sacrifices or
greatest moves of all time feel free to
let me know
those as well but thank you guys so much
for watching this video
always appreciate you watching and i'll
see you guys next time
you